bonjour bienvenue dans ces autres cas
dit ce matin avec marcellin nadeau
bonjour bonjour vers 5 heures rue
georges aux auditrices et auditeurs de
martine la première radio je salue leur
sens de l'équipe de matinale est bonne
et heureuse année à toutes et à tous
merci pareil moi avoue le maire du
prêcheur et coprésident du parti pays
alors on va y aller tout de suite parce
que le temps est court on le sait
d'abord un regard sur ce qui se passe
aux etats unis
marcellin nadeau les états unis
longtemps présenté comme modèle de
démocratie par beaucoup alors le citoyen
martiniquais mais hommes politiques
aussi que vous n'êtes que pense-t-il de
cette fin de mandat présidentiel de
donald trump et quel sens lui donner si
ça peut prendre au sens ce qui voit
aujourd'hui dans le monde on vit une
situation particulière je dirais que
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins
entre ses aspirations démocratiques on
voit aussi la poussée notamment de
l'écologie de l'écologie politique bien
même temps c'est avec un danger
populiste pas seulement aux états unis
d'ailleurs mis en oeuvre en europe et
ailleurs et s'agissant de la états unis
comme modèle de vous doter ailleurs en
martinique même on pourrait ne pas être
à l'abri moment je n'irai pas jusque là
parce que nous n'avons pour tous les
leviers de pouvoir étatique je les temps
par exemple dans le système en europe je
crois que y compris dans le système
duquel nous relevons je crois qu'il ya
un danger populiste assez c'est évident
et comme les états unis vont mettre dans
les états unis modèle de démocratie bon
ça aussi à un élément intéressant je dis
souvent que nous sommes comme les états
unis une nation américaine c'est à dire
la particularité nash américaines se
sont pas des nations mono ethnique se
sont plutôt plus rhétiques
maintenant mon c'est un système dit
démocratique qui s'est aussi modèle
économique un modèle économique et
social qui n'est pas fondamentalement le
lien et se pose aussi aux états unis la
question des d égalité et la question je
me pose au fond c'est de savoir si à une
démocratie réelle possible avec un
système complètement inégalitaire
en une phrase vous salue et l'accession
à la vice présidence des états unis
d'une femme d'origine en partie
caribéenne à l'issue d'un père jamaïcain
et d'une mère indienne
c'est toujours à l'art il s'est toujours
à saluer quand des gens dits delà des
minorités visibles entre guillemets
accepte ça prouve on n'a pas besoin de
le prouver que nous sommes des êtres à
part entière tout monde semoun ben je ne
me fais aucune sorte d'illusion sur la
administration médical mais ce que je
dis c'est qu'il ya quelques éléments
rupture avec trump sur la question de
l'écologie par exemple le fait de de
reprendre la dynamique de la coop 21 et
de la question du changement climatique
me paraît être salutaire pour la planète
entière marcenat de vous êtes co
présidents de pays a le parti politique
à ces jeunes en martinique alors vous
assurez la coprésidence avec jean
philippe miller le député jean philippe
miller le coprésident de pays a que vous
êtes comment accueil t-il la
confirmation et l'officialisation public
là ce week-end dernier de l'entrée en
campagne du mime et de son président
alfred marie jeanne
par ailleurs président sortant du
conseil exécutif de la ctm et donc ils
ont annoncé leur entrée en campagne pour
tenter de garder la main sur la
collectivité territoriale dont ce n'est
pas un scoop
bref tout le monde s'y attendait mais
temps là la question que je me pose
c'est de savoir à quand franchement la
relève politique dans ce pays
je crois que je lui ai dit je le répète
sont visibles j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour alfred marie-jeanne comme pour
d'autres leaders martiniquais cela étant
la question qui se pose est ce une
question qui est posée par rapport je
vais dire à la société martiniquaise et
la politique la martinique qui est par
trop masculiniser trop âgés et donc il
faut plus de femmes et plus de jeunes
dans les dynamiques politiques de notre
pays et c'est ce que nous essayons de
faire écho à payer oui il ya l'âge et
puis à la longévité aussi de la carrière
elle-même enfin de comment on pèse
finalement sur les le fonctionnement les
institutions du territoire prennent
personnellement mais ça dépasse aka
personnes alfred marie-jeanne je n'aime
pas les divas de personnes je suis
plutôt partisan d'une limitation des
mandats limitation des mandats dans le
temps de l'espace à dire le nombre de
mandats d'une part et puis je crois
effectivement qu'il faut savoir passer
la main et limité parce que je le vois
bien moi je dis je le dis je le répète
je ne ferai pas un quatrième mandat au
prêcheur c'est parce que je sens le
besoin aussi d'une rayure est urgent d
origine à sion une redynamisation et je
crois qu'il faut des fois des personnes
nouvelles poivre un autre regard et
redynamise un petit peu les choses comme
alors peut-être certains électeurs vont
estimer que pays a procède de cela mais
en tout cas vous même dans ce parti vous
êtes certainement phase de mise en place
d'une liste qui serait capable d'obtenir
une majorité de votes pour la prochaine
élection à la ctm alors comment ça se
passe
et est ce que vous êtes conforté dans
l'idée qu'il faut y aller
ouais finalement mais évidemment pas
seul et donc du coup qu'il faut trouver
les bons compagnons les partenaires
efficaces
alors moi je crois qu'effectivement le
pays a besoin d'une autre dynamique
d'une alternative pour ça fait longtemps
que je le dis même avant que jeunes
appartiennent à pays acp
il faut sortir de la bipolarisation il
faut une autre alternative est dessus je
crois qu aussi qu'il y à la question des
urgences je crois que nous sommes
confrontés alors bien sûr il ya
l'urgence climatique et planétaire en
parlais tout à l'heure des états unis
mais aussi des urgences martiniquaise
comment on peut être au 21ème siècle
confronté à un problème de distribution
d'eau un problème de déplacement
transport des problèmes de logement un
problème d'attractivité nos jeunes qui
partent et le problème crucial la
martinique qui est un pays qui fouillent
halo fallait la zec des inégalités
territoriales à s'associer c'est un défi
collectif qui se présent cela et à la
société martiniquaise 1 s'est passé et
bien sûr nous allons la faire notre
assemblée générale le 17 quoi pays aux
prochains pays à attaque donc très bonne
règle générale en forme de rentrer polio
s'il y avait un moment un moment de
rentrée politique
nous allons d'abord valider notre
manifeste parce qu'un parti politique
c'est un socle de valeurs
donc nous avons élaboré pris le temps
d'élaborer ce manifeste qui sera validé
l'ordonnancé notre assemblée générale
nous annoncerons celui ou celle qui
conduira que nous proposons à la
conduite du nice en tout cas notre
souhait c'est celui de cr également
c'est opter pour le plus étonnant le
plus large contre le plus étroit
rassemblés dimanche devant le but alors
je vais voir cela la dot quelles bases
mais sur des bases sur des valeurs et
sur des orientations notamment pas voir
ces questions d'urgence martin et donc
vous êtes en train de jouer pas dire
vous n'êtes pas en tractation parce que
le terme que je n'aime pas mais
justement il peut être péjoratif c'est
vrai mais est ce que vous êtes en
contact en négociation en discussion en
dialogue avec d'autres mouvements
politiques avec d'autres personnalités
bien sûr nous sommes en discussion avec
le rdm nous sommes en discussion avec
les ateliers cherché wa avec quelques
élus mais quand nous rencontrons les
personnes il ne s'agit pas de
tractations mais nous leur disons mais
sur quoi nous pouvons nous entendre par
rapport aux urgences martiniquaise sait
quels objectifs nous pouvons nous
assigner et c'est ça c'est à dire que
sortir des tractations pour entrer dans
la co construction d'un projet pour la
martinique et je crois qu'il ya trop de
tractations pas assez de co construction
et nous paye à nous prenons vraiment
nous faisons le pari d'une possible co
construction d'un intérêt du pays alors
il vous faudra quand même tirer le bilan
de la mandature alors une partie de la
majorité sortante là alors on le sait
majorité désormais quand même
passablement éclaté et bien une partie
de la majorité sortante a récemment tiré
son bilan de la mandature qui s'achève
bilan au taux jugé satisfaisant mais ce
que vous vous n'avez que des critiques à
émettre a affaire à formuler vis-à-vis
de ces six dernières années à la forêt
rites et les systèmes d'auto évaluation
et d'autosatisfaction
je crois qu'il faut une véritable
démarche d'évaluation des politiques
publiques alors c'est vrai que la mode
majorité sortante nous avait promis une
évaluation qu'on n'a jamais vus voler
toujours facile de dire oui j'ai bien
fait tout est bon tout est beau quand je
ne dis pas que tout est mauvais il ya
des choses positives
bon une tentative de rôle d'organiser le
transport représente me paraît salutaire
sauf qu'il ya beaucoup pas fait encore
pour sept contre je discute avec mes
administrés du prêcheur ils sont pas
fondamentalement satisfaits du système
actuel mais il ya une volonté
cela étant une comme diraient les
français français une hirondelle ne fait
pas le printemps
c'est pas parce qu'on a pris on a fait
quelques réalisations le lycée cherche
et c'est là que tout de suite on est
dans la bonne voie
je vois que ce qui manque à ce petit jeu
pour un seul exemple pour être concret
c'est là qu'est la question alimentaire
la question de l'agriculture
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui une
collectivité comme la ctm qui a des
leviers énorme en matière de
développement agricole et de
l'alimentation
parce que là c'est mgr tous les toutes
les cantines scolaires du second degré
n'est pas un projet alimentaire
territoriale projet alimentateur que
nous avons mis en place au prêcheur avec
un diagnostic qui nous permet de voir
par exemple que 42% des denrées c'est
via nos enfants vont à la poubelle que
quatre
vingt dix pour cent des produits
consommés chez nous viennent de l'axé et
pendant que 90% de production d'ailleurs
on a besoin de ce type d'outil justement
afrique diagnostic prospectif pour
élaborer un projet sur la question
alimentaire exemple alors que nous avons
un réel besoin alors qu'à les
pathologies liées à l'alimentation
alors que notre agriculture est en crise
elle se cherche je pense qu'on devrait
sur ce terrain là notamment avoir un
vrai projet alimenter un territoriale
pour la martinique voilà alors marcellin
nadeau le maire du prêcheur que vous
êtes on s'adressait davantage au
président du parti politique paya mais
là le maire du prêcheur a eu et a encore
fort à faire avec l'activité du volcan
voisin de la commune alors on n'a pas le
temps d'en parler en détail vous
reviendrez certainement pour cela mais
vient d'être mise en place ainsi il ya
une semaine un comité de vigilance
montagne pelée avec le président de cap
nord 1 tenait donc une association une
collaboration avec bruno à 0 pour une
cause essentielle la wii mais on
comprend bien mais cette nouvelle donne
pourrait elle annoncé un partenariat
prochain par exemple pour la campagne
électorale de là c'était très court
parce qu'il faut manger il faut savoir
ce pays fait la transition entre les os
et options politiques électorales je
dirais politicienne et la nécessité que
nous avons nous élus martiniquais de
nous mettre ensemble au travail je salue
d'ailleurs le fait que nous soyons
accordez-vous nunès oiseaux et moi sur
cet objectif là qui est de faire en
sorte que les martiniquais n'attendent
pas toujours de l'autre qu'ils règlent
leurs problèmes et c'est vrai que nous
sommes souvent infantiliser sur cette
question de risque majeur nous ne sommes
contre personne nous voulons travailler
alors tout le monde mais nous voulons
avoir notre autonomie de réfection nous
appuyons sur une ressource
intellectuelle le les travaux de nos
chercheurs comme seule université en
type exemple ou des historiens martinek
fang au travail sur cette question de
destruction de l'amour verra si ça donne
quelque chose j'espère en tout cas la
zone avant halloween on met plus loin
peut-être en termes de partenariat
politique de l'un d'eux la cause de la
montagne pelée il faut distinguer les
chaleurs ma vie legault 30 66 en 30
secondes
à propos de la transition énergétique et
par exemple de l'installation de plus en
plus de doughty photovoltaïque de panne
ou fold photovoltaïque on cite l exemple
du prêcheur qui d'un coup à un ami un
braquet plus plus important en équipant
l'ensemble de ses bâtiments municipaux
de panneaux photovoltaïques mais on sait
que la ville du prêcheur avec quelques
autres communes
la martinique sont pionnières en la
matière donc là le braquet a été
nettement mis plus largement par exemple
lorrains mais est-ce qu'il sera pas
vocation à essaimer dans l'île dans son
volume là cette ampleur là d'une manière
générale la transition énergétique en 30
secondes
non le précieux est la première commune
qui est eric roy neiges positif la
croissance verte depuis ségolène royal
donc ça fait longtemps mais je veux dire
que la question énergétique au prêcheur
n'est pas une seule question isolés nous
nativement dans un projet global de
transition écologique devant les députés
le ministre de la santé entendu
actuellement par la commission des
affaires sociales il sera devant les
sénateurs à 17 heures